[Applaudissements]
juste vraiment sur le déclin touche pas
à mon poste on a battu encore des
records de la semaine dernière donc
merci bfm
occupez vous de vous je pense que vous
avez déjà beaucoup bonheur c'est juste
parce que pour le coup bfmtv c'est
plutôt buzz fm tv essayer d'être bon sur
les informations et s'est pas posé de
problème dans des moments dit délicat et
faites votre travail je pense que c'est
déjà beaucoup pour vous voilà non mais
c'est vrai que ce sera déjà bon et là où
laurent rue thiers raison moi j'ai
halluciné je vais pas là cités ça leur
ferait trop d'honneur mais il y avait
une radio qui était en train de faire
justement un papier en disant mais on
comprend pas la vacuité de cette
émission pourquoi est ce que tout le
monde part de la jirs va pas parler de
ce nom mais je me disais mais dans ces
cas là pourquoi vous